[Music]
rodney harrison loved playing against
quarterbacks like that the football
night in america analyst two-time super
bowl champ and hopefully on the doorstep
of being a hall of famer one day
steelers taking on the chargers sunday
night football rodney joins us on the
program rod how are you this morning
good morning dan how are you sir i'm
good i'm curious how bill belichick
would defend mac jones
well he's a rookie quarterback and just
like most rookie quarterbacks and you've
seen the baltimore ravens you've seen
mike zimmer the minnesota vikings you've
seen the patriots do the same thing
against justin herbert so they don't
care these defensive coordinators don't
care how good you are how good of a
young player you are they're going to
show you different looks they're going
to try to confuse you they're going to
pressure you and that's what you're
seeing from a lot of these defensive
coordinators going against young
quarterbacks zach wilson is one of them
and you know even joe burrow you see
these defensive coordinators trying to
create confusion
and um get these guys to throw
interceptions and that's what they've
been doing are you all in on mac jones
the love from absolutely yeah that's
absolutely i've been like i thought that
was distilled draft i mean you know when
kyle shanahan had an opportunity i think
at the three spot or whatever
to grab him i was hoping that he didn't
get him because i'm like this dude fits
perfectly i mean for him to be able to
go in from nick saban system to bill
belichick system and basically just
change
jerseys and you know two very similar
guys that do things a certain way i
thought it was a blessing but do you see
and i know this is a dangerous
comparison but let me compare to brady
first starting with new england mac
jones first starting is mac ahead of
schedule
from where tom brady was
i think i think i don't know about all
that all i know is this this is a young
good player he's a guy that works hard
he puts his team first he cares about
winning he cares about preparation he
cares about doing all the little things
and i think you see that the patriots
are starting to come together as a team
all the fundamentals all the little
things that coach belichick teaches
these guys are starting to trust and
believing and you you're starting to see
it they're starting to win football
games there okay this
let me just say this this is a very good
young quarterback he doesn't make a lot
of mistakes he's very tough on himself
and he stays in the moment that's what
they tell me he's so focused and he
stays in the moment that you know he's
just he's just a really good smart
football player and they love him why do
you think the niners decided that they
were going to take trey lance instead of
mack jones probably public pressure i
mean everybody wants to get into this i
need an athletic quarterback i need an
athletic quarterback yeah he can run
around you know and do all these
incredible plays at times but you need
somebody that can sit in the pocket read
the defenses communicate to the offense
get everybody in the right position and
sometimes that's not sexy enough a lot
of these you know coaches they fall
pressure you know fall to the pressure
of the public man and when you get a guy
like matt jones who's smart who puts the
team first who does things right i don't
see how you can bypass a guy like that
and ultimately when you make a decision
like that it can all ultimately cost you
your job look look what's going on in in
chicago with matt and aggie i mean how
many times does he get to screw up a
quarterback situation
and keep a job
well he might have gotten this one right
with justin fields
well
it's not like they're getting it right
because they still haven't done a good
job of putting that offensive line in
front of the guy you know what i'm
saying it's like it's crazy well that's
why i always go back to andrew luckrod
and it's nice to have a 100 million
dollar quarterback but if you got you
know a 25 offensive line
then it's a poor investment and i think
andrew luck fell out of love with
football he was getting beat up and he
was still a very good quarterback but he
wasn't being protected they finally got
around to protecting him and then he's
like i'm going to check out i don't want
to play anymore and then i think and
then think of this too i mean just
because you're a great football player
doesn't mean that you want to play 20
years in nfl you know guys have goals
hey i want to play 10 years in the
league i want to make my money save my
money and move on and do something else
it's nothing wrong with that and just
because andrew luck was a household name
he's a big time quarterback he was the
first pick overall doesn't mean that he
wants to stay in the league forever you
know especially getting your brains beat
out with a garbage offensive line
is ben roethlisberger still a good
quarterback
no
he's smart
you know he can make he can make some
throws but you can't depend on him you
don't know what he's going to give you
every single week i love big ben and ben
should be in a hall of fame i played
against ben he's the ultimate competitor
but at this time of stage in his career
he's a guy that's leading those young
guys he's more of a mentor to him but
when i watch him play he's not very good
is brady better at anything now than he
was
five years ago
i think he's just really good at
everything because like you know when
you talk to him the rules have changed
which really helped the offensive
players he you know he has said hey man
defensive players can't do anything the
game's gotten easier so the game has
gotten easier because you can't put your
hands on the guys anytime you throw it
down the field you bump a receiver the
flags are coming out so he just always
tells hey man i feel so bad for you guys
because you guys can't play defense
anymore
how would you defend odell beckham
how would i defend him yeah
i really don't have to defend him if
if this team's not throwing him the ball
he's a talented young man and i talked
to him when he was in atlanta in the
preseason dan the kid just wants to play
football he's not into all this other
crazy stuff that he was into before he
just wants to go out there and play
football and it's going to take some
time to implement in the offense but to
me like how hard is it to throw elderly
back on the screen how hard is it throw
him a slap round how hard is it to tell
him to run a deep dig at 12 yards and
come inside like to me
all you have to do is give him an
opportunity and these offensive
coordinators are making it so difficult
with a guy with that level of talent
just throw him the damn ball that's all
you have to do and give him a chance but
you look at the rams they're going all
in they're trading people and they don't
understand like it comes down to
chemistry if you if you have chemistry
on your team you're gonna have a chance
of winning and also you look at matthew
stafford what the heck is he doing is
this the matthew stafford that we saw in
detroit like what's going on with him he
can't just drop back and throw the ball
up for grabs like who does that
well normally we didn't focus on matthew
stafford playing an entire game because
we didn't watch the lines now he's on
display and now people are you know
tuning in and watching these throws and
now you're playing on a bigger stage the
stakes are extremely high
super bowl or bust and i think that's
what i want to watch the second half of
the season and if they make it to the
postseason there's certain guys when
they get to the postseason they become a
different player whether that's good or
bad
yeah absolutely and a lot of pressures
on sean mcveigh because he traded got
rid of jared goff and remember these are
the same dudes that gave jared goff over
100 million bucks and then you get then
you give up the house and you get rid of
players you don't have a first round
pick for the next three four years
they better win and the way von miller
looked at times the other week last week
he didn't look like you know the von
miller that i'm used to seeing so if i'm
the rams i got a lot of question marks
and it starts with sean mcvay rodney
harrison nbc football night in america
and of course won two super bowls with
uh the patriots um the defense being
employed against kansas city what
exactly is different this year than
previous years of how teams are playing
patrick mahomes
well before i guess teams when they
first didn't really know patrick mahomes
they came out and tried to blitz him and
play man-to-man and all these different
things but most teams are just keeping
two safeties deep and saying patrick you
know what we know you want to throw the
ball down the field we're gonna take
away these um these big plays down the
field and we're gonna force you to go up
and down the field eight to ten twelve
play drives and see if you can stay
patient enough to do that and before he
said that was something that he
struggled with but like when i picked
him kansas city against the raiders i
just knew that andy reid would make the
necessary adjustments these this is an
offense that's been to the last two
super bowls kansas city is gonna be
right there i don't care how they're
looking talk to chris jones that defense
is gonna improve but that offense is
gonna be right there at the end of the
season dan where do you stand with the
taunting rule with the nfl
i don't like it i get it i get it you
know the rule is the rule and players
have to respect the rule but at the same
time i've always said these are the best
2 000 players in the world like come on
man like these guys are getting paid
millions of dollars you know let them
celebrate let them have fun you know
that's what the game is about other
players know because they've been on a
receiving end as well like we like to
celebrate as players and when somebody
else is celebrating you got to let them
celebrate give them their props and keep
it moving but i just think the nfl needs
to loosen up man this is you know this
is the nfl this we should be having fun
man shouldn't have to worry about no
taunting
you didn't taunt
i didn't have to because i mean like i
hit you to hit you and get back up and
say hey i'm coming back to you
hey let me just say this to you
um
let me just say this like like if
somebody needs a shot lesson they need
to come to you
i mean your jump shot is money i
remember us at sam flood's house oh
producer we went out there for
thanksgiving
and rodney was talking a lot a lot of
junk and i said rod
like i'll go out but you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna crush you like i got i was
like
i was mad at him and we went outside
turned on the spotlight
and i i just i think i took a shot and
it's in the air and i just kept walking
to the house i was so mad that you made
me go outside
i loved it i'm the tom brady of backyard
basketball
man let me tell you we had some great
times man
i i'm hey i miss being in the studio
with you
i had so much fun with you and and tony
i mean that that's what made that so
much fun is and you talk about this with
chemistry as a player and tony as a
coach when you have trust in each other
it was just a lot of fun and and you
guys came in and had the right approach
you said treat us like rookies we have
to learn tv and a lot of times people
come in and they go i just put on a
microphone and a suit and tie and talk
and uh i just didn't want to sugarcoat
it i wanted to make sure you guys
learned how to do it and then you'd be
teaching
other guys who came in so
you know you guys listen
no doubt bro we we definitely appreciate
it and we would not have lasted i mean
this is year 13 on that show and you
know my role is a little different i'm
at the stadium but you know to be able
to do that show with you as long as i've
done it and learn as much and absorb all
of the knowledge and wisdom that you've
given me i definitely appreciate it i
know coach feels the same way dan what
is it like though to be on the field and
want to hit somebody like do you get it
it's awesome just like um your boy i
knocked out remember it um you're
that was a cheap shot oh my god that was
one of the great setups where we're like
mclovin's gonna act like a quarterback
and then rodney's gonna act like he's
gonna hit you and rodney popped mclovin
that's a 15-yard flag if i've ever seen
one in my life nope that was not that
was clean
and you know what and it was probably
worth a twenty thousand dollars
how much were you finding your career
a little over 300 000
[Laughter]
what was the one that was absolutely
worth it
oh jerry rice
and you know what it was amazing that
they would find me a game check and back
then i think the game check was a
hundred and maybe twenty thousand
dollars so it was some really good money
especially from a kid coming from
illinois that's a lot of money to give
up but jerry rice did that slant and i
got a chance to hit him and i'll tell
you dan i would have spent a half a
million bucks on that just to get a
chance to knock his freaking head off as
much as i loved jerry rice
it was awesome but but why do you want
to light up jerry rice
because he's the enemy he's the receiver
all offensive players are the enemy you
know that and i love jerry rice i mean i
got a chance as a young player to see
him practice and practice against the
san francisco 49ers and his work ethic
and discipline but when it came down to
that game i was not afraid
of jerry rice and i wanted him to know
my name did you need to get fined should
you have been fined for the hit
no i don't think so i mean if anything
should have been like but you know what
then i had a reputation and you know
people at the front office really you
know they had it kind of had it out for
me and it was all good like i said you
can't miss something that you never had
but do you write a check to the nfl back
then or they take it just out of your
your is it like direct
withdrawal
well they just you just don't collect a
check
you know you look at your bank account
you see all those zeros
and then you see
[Laughter]
were you married at the time
um
98 no i wasn't i wasn't married but you
know i had mom that i was taking care of
and stuff like that and i told her i was
like mom listen i said i got
hey i got some money i got a little
money
and i and i would have a lot more money
if i didn't keep hitting guys
hey but you know what man you know you
can't you can't slow a guy like me down
you know obviously i have to play
smarter at times
but you always want a young guy that's
hungry that's physical to kind of do
their thing but you couldn't play like
that now
yeah and i probably would have lasted 20
years too i mean think about it the guys
are getting paid a heck of a lot more
money you can't hit
just watch when they play they don't
even tackle anymore they tackle the
football they just tackle the football
and everybody tries to go for the
football and then the convoy just goes 5
10 15 yards right into the end zone it's
crazy it's different the way they play
football yeah and the role of the safety
like it feels like the role that
although jamal adams does play with the
physicality there but you know
the days of ronnie lot
those are long gone aren't they
yeah definitely because like i see
referees or officials calling flags
and it's not even a legal hit but it's
because of the severity of the hit how
hard someone hit now you can hit the guy
the same way but if you kind of just hit
them and lay them down it won't be a
flag but if you just absolutely run
through them they're throwing flags from
everywhere and it's like it has to be an
egregious hit it can't be just because
it's a very physical hit you're throwing
flags who was that running back when he
came through it was like this gonna hurt
brandon jacobs jamal lewis from the
baltimore ravens
um i was a young young player with barry
sanders he juked me one time at the goal
line stuck his head down ran me over on
monday night football and ran me over
and that was my introduction to the
league and after that then i said i'm
gonna do more squats i'm gonna do i'm
gonna get my legs stronger because he
would embarrass me as a young player
barry embarrassed a lot of people
yes he did but it was fantastic man
hey tell everybody i said hello always
great to talk to you hope family's great
buddy
you too buddy good to see you thank you
that's rodney harrison nbc football
night in america and won two super bowls
with the patriots